Hoy, Pizarritas, hemos preparado un Q&A de lo más completo,
ya que en estas últimas semanas estamos hablando mucho de Madrid,
Barça y Atlético de Madrid,
pues hoy nos vamos a centrar en los otros 17.
¿Qué pasa, Pizarritas?
Ya estamos aquí con un nuevo Q&A centrado en la Liga española
a partir, básicamente, de la cuarta posición,
porque, insisto, ya estábamos hablando mucho de Barça y Real Madrid,
sobre todo de ellos dos, también habíamos hablado del tema Griezmann,
habíamos hablado mucho de la Atleti en anteriores Q&A,
y digo, bueno, vamos a centrarnos en el resto también,
que son muy importantes aquí en nuestro canal.
¿Qué tal, Adrián Blanco, Álex de Jan, Unauel Miranda, cómo estáis?
¿Qué tal, chicos? Muy buenas.
¿Cómo estamos?
¿Qué tal? Muy buenas.
¿Os parece bien la idea de preguntarles, primero,
a los Pizarritas por otros temas
y que sean ellos los que nos lancen los debates?
Pues hoy vamos a hablar de Real Sociedad, de Sevilla, de Villarreal,
del descenso, de cuestiones generales también bonitas.
¿Os parece correcto?
Siempre hablamos de todo, Miguel.
Lo paso siempre... Hay alguno que llora, pero siempre hablamos de todo.
No, no, no, pero fíjate, no ha sido nada...
No he escuchado comentarios al respecto,
pero sí que es verdad que me gusta, al final de cada semana,
echar una vista atrás a lo que hemos hecho en el canal
y, claro, al final, la Copa del Rey,
la Champions con el Barça, la renovación de Griezmann.
Ostras, estábamos haciendo demasiado de esos tres
y me parece una bonita forma de compensarlo
y sé que nuestros Pizarritas, que son la gran mayoría de Barça,
María Atleti, también creen en nuestro contenido
y en el contenido de la Liga española,
así que sé que también van a dar like,
porque, por ejemplo, la primera cuestión...
Creo que es una cuestión interesante, de verdad, sí, al turrón.
Adrian Blanco pregunta Gaucha Pastor.
Teniendo en cuenta la política de fichajes del IMP,
que sería algo bastante complejo de explicar, analizar...
De hecho, me parece bastante atrevido llamarle política, ¿vale?
Aunque solo sea por rentabilidad a futuro,
no veis completamente obligatorio traer en propiedad
a Enzo Barrenechea.
Hay que recordar, Adri, que no hay opción de compra,
como sí en el caso de Omar Sadik.
Sí, hay que negociar por Barrenechea.
A ver, sí, sería una grandísima opción para el Valencia,
porque creo que está rindiendo muy bien
y me parece un futbolista de nivel...
Top, de nivel muy importante para el equipo.
Pero, como es todo lo que es en Ameriton,
como ya sabemos qué pasa con Peter Lin,
ya veremos qué pasa en verano, pero sí,
probablemente sería un gran acierto por parte de Valencia
para quedarse al jugador, para sacar una plusvalía.
¿De cuántos millones estamos hablando, Álex?
Más o menos.
Pues yo creo que...
Yo creo que veniendo de Aston Villa y demás,
yo creo que no va a bajar de los 30 o 35.
Es que ahí no...
Me parece inviable.
O sea, yo primero creo que me parece inviable por el Aston Villa,
o sea, porque además lo obtienen en una operación muy bien trabajada
al dejar ir a Douglas Lewis a la Juve.
Y yo creo que ahí negocia muy bien el Aston Villa
y se hace con un futbolista, obviamente, del futuro.
Pero sí que vería viable una cesión de un año más.
O sea, ahí no sé si el Aston Villa va a primar...
Oye, prefiero que se vaya a fútbol inglés,
que empiece a coger ritmo a Premier, etcétera, y tal,
o que continúe con un entrenador que le está haciendo crecer como Corberán.
Nada, a mí me parece muy improbable.
Creo que es un jugador que ha demostrado estar por encima
de la realidad del Valencia ahora mismo, en el pretexto deportivo.
Así que entre que la política no existe
en materia deportiva del Valencia,
va a ser un verano muy raro el Valencia.
Nadie ha entendido todavía de dónde sale la idea de traer a Corberán,
de dónde aparece el dinero.
Yo con los cambios en la directiva estaba convencido
de que Corona tenía los días contados y todavía sigue en el club.
Entonces, es un verano muy raro,
pero como en veranos normales de lo que ha venido siendo el Valencia
en los últimos años, lo vería imposible.
Otra cosa es que cambie la realidad, que cambie el contexto del Valencia,
y podemos estar hablando de otras cosas.
Evidentemente, entre Aston Villa y Valencia
hay una conexión bastante potente.
Básicamente, por ejemplo, por el caso de Damien Abidagain,
que le conocemos nosotros de sobra,
que le hemos tenido también de compañero en Radio Marca.
Ahí puede haber una buena relación,
pero si Emery lo necesita o si el Aston Villa recibe una gran oferta,
creo que excede las posibilidades del Valencia.
Lo que sí que creo es que es una pena,
sobre todo para el Valencia, pero también, evidentemente, para la Liga,
que esa política de fichajes que podía ser, no sé si inicial,
pero sí en un punto intermedio del proyecto LIM,
de buscar jugadores con rentabilidad a futuro,
se haya quedado realmente en la nada, porque no es la realidad.
Es decir, el Valencia no se ha convertido en un Dormoon Lite
o en un LIL, que esto también lo ha hecho, no.
El Valencia se ha ido descapitalizando y ha ido fichando...
hombre, está muy feo decir...
Sí, gracias por el término, porque a mí se me iba a ocurrir uno más feo.
Fichando retales con lo que podía,
recordamos el caso de Carlos Vicente, que es paradigmático,
lo que costó traer...
A Canos.
A Canos, que luego, bueno, es que luego el nivel de ser de Canos,
por muy valencianista que sea, también es el que es...
Ostras, es que no hemos visto, insisto, un proyecto ni una política,
es básicamente un...
Salve si hay quien pueda, vamos a tratar de mantener el club
en primera edición, con lo mínimo posible, y a partir de ahí, tirar.
Entonces, claro, un jugador como Barrem Echea y otro como Marsadik,
o cambia la realidad del Valencia o parece complicada.
Óscar Álvarez pregunta por cómo valoramos la apuesta de la Real
por Sergio Francisco, y nos repregunta si hubiéramos preferido
que fueran a por Michel, cómo se llegó a rumorear.
A ver, a mí me parece que tiene sentido el tema de Sergio Francisco
y que creo que es una apuesta coherente
dentro de lo que es la Real Sociedad como club
y de lo que están queriendo transmitir también dentro de este proyecto.
Se va a Olave, Bretos.
Se va a Immanuel, Sergio Francisco.
Se va a Zubimendi, X medio centro de Zubieta.
Yo le veo sentido a lo que está ocurriendo en la Real Sociedad.
A mí me parecía que lo de Michel podía ser interesante,
pero sí que es verdad que la Real Sociedad y la prensa de Donosti,
lo que están exponiendo todos los datos, que la Real Sociedad no tenía tiempo.
O sea, no podía esperar a una decisión de un entrenador
o no podía dejar que el proyecto no cogiera ese ritmo desde ya.
De hecho, Sergio Francisco, si no me equivoco,
creo que no va a dirigir hasta el final de temporada.
Ya está trabajando en planificación de plantilla
y el otro día a Álex con John Cuesva, Joaquín Aperriba.
Luego estas cosas, yo me creo la mitad de la mitad,
porque luego lo que nos explican siempre son relatos muy convenientes.
Porque claro, cada uno está dando su versión y quiere quedar bien,
no va a quedar mal.
Pero Joaquín Aperriba y el presidente de la Real Sociedad
dijo que una vez Immanuel le pide tiempo,
Aperriba le tranquilizó diciendo,
oye, Ima, tranquilo, porque si tú te vas,
es que tenemos a Sergio Francisco.
Bueno, yo no sé si ha sido así, no tengo información al respecto.
Me parece una visión bastante cómoda,
pero es evidente que sí que hay una línea ahí.
O sea, tú crees que si, por ejemplo,
el Girona ya no tiene objetivo esta temporada,
o sea, está salvado y no puede llegar a Europa,
¿tú crees que no hubiera sido Sergio Francisco?
No lo sé, no lo sé.
Lo que creo es que estas cuestiones,
aunque siempre se están preparando,
o sea, quiero decir, siempre cuando sabes que ZubyMendi empieza a destacar,
la Real Sociedad debe llevar mirando a medios centros, ¿qué?
¿Tres años?
Por si pasa eso.
Entonces, con entrenadores probablemente algo parecido.
No dudo que fuese el primer plan,
pero también creo que hay cosas que el mercado,
¿quién decía esto? Que es un organismo vivo, ¿no?
Va cambiando, va mutando,
y si no, que se lo digan a Carlo Ancelotti y a Brasil.
Y imagínate que aparece la opción de Michel muy clara,
que el Girona está salvado y Michel dice,
oye, mira, no voy a seguir, como ha pasado en muchos equipos,
pues a mí me parecía un nombre planteable,
pero bueno, que me parece que es una línea lógica de la Real Sociedad.
Sin conocer a Sergio Francisco,
es imposible valorar cómo de buen entrenador es, honestamente.
Claro, a ver, yo estoy de acuerdo que es una línea lógica
por el plan de la Real, por su metodología de trabajo,
estoy de acuerdo con vosotros y al mismo tiempo
me parece un mensaje importante de puertas hacia dentro
y también hacia fuera.
Oye, rebajamos un poquito las pretensiones,
rebajamos un poquito el objetivo,
porque creo que haber traído a Michel o a Lopetegui,
que eran los entrenadores que sonaban,
creo que hubiese sido darle mucha más presión
y decir, oye, vamos a dar un golpe más,
vamos a dar un paso adelante más con un entrenador
que lo viene haciendo muy bien,
o un entrenador ya contrastado, como el caso de Jules.
Y bueno, yo coincido con vosotros
y habría que empezar a trabajar un mote
para Sergio Francisco.
Sergio Francisco le falta un poquito de punch y de carisma,
así que yo invito al pizarrismo a que...
Bueno, igual ya lo tiene y no lo conocemos,
en fin, que nos lo cuenten un poquito.
Pero no crees...
No crees que es importante dejarle trabajar,
es decir, a ver cómo es, ¿no?
O sea, quiere decir, igual el mote, como quien dice,
nos lo aporta a él directamente.
Sí, igual sale solo una vez lo escuchemos hablar.
Claro, mira, por ejemplo, Iñigo Pérez,
un entrenador que, a ver, supercarisma no tiene,
no habla demasiado con los medios, no se da mucha importancia...
Pero a Iñigo Pérez le pega llamarse Iñigo Pérez.
Sí, pero, por ejemplo...
Pero él...
Y ese estar en segundo plano, ese...
Pero al mismo tiempo hemos visto una narrativa
con Iñigo Pérez y la climatología
que le podemos llamar el Rebequitas,
porque nunca se la pone, siempre va en manga corta.
Entonces, no sé, quiero decir,
hay que dejar a Sergio Francisco trabajar
en todos los sentidos posibles para ver cómo le va.
Que si le llamáramos directamente por el...
Me parece que es el segundo apellido, a Sergio Ramos.
Uf. Hola.
Sergio Francisco Ramos.
O le podemos llamar el Camero.
Sin ningún sentido, además.
Bueno...
Hay que dar la propuesta.
Me gusta porque... Claro.
SF...
Es que, claro, si fuese JR...
O sea...
JL...
Pero SF...
Habrá que preguntarle a John Cuesba.
Porque luego John se saca algo así como el Gitano de Orio.
Que nadie lo veía venir.
Bueno, pero esto no fue John, eh.
Esto fue Imanol en una rueda de prensa
que dice que soy el Gitano de Orio.
Me parece una maravilla.
Y si pierde tres partidos seguidos,
yo espero que de una entrevista despierta a Sergio Francisco, ¿no?
Por eso hay que dejarle trabajar.
Hay que dejarle trabajar y ya haremos nosotros lo nuestro.
Corpas soldados.
Siguiendo un poquito la cuestión de Michel,
que también nos la lanzaba antes Óscar Álvarez,
se mete en la situación del Sevilla.
La ABC en Sevilla hablaba de Michel y de Bórdalas
como futuros entrenadores del Sevilla.
Agua y aceite, aceite y agua.
Cenar una pizza y unas palomitas
o una ensaladita de tomate y queso de Burgos, ¿vale?
Creo que esto explica el contraste
entre cómo siente el club la directiva
y cómo lo siente Víctor Horta.
Pero en todo caso, os quiero preguntar por esta opción.
¿Qué os gustaría más?
¿Qué os encaja más?
Y qué significado puede tener una cosa u otra para la plantilla.
Porque aquí Corpas Soldados también nos preguntaba
por jugadores que ganarían o perderían de la mano de José Bórdalas.
A ver, yo creo que el tema de Bórdalas...
Me parece que creo que ninguna plantilla...
O sea, que Bórdalas siempre va a ser capaz de sacarle algo,
sea cual sea la plantilla.
Es decir, creo que es un entrenador que tiene esa capacidad
de ser camaleónico y de que su plan
no se ciña tanto a los jugadores,
sino directamente a lo que pueden dar sobre el terreno del juego.
Dicho esto...
Agumé, capitán general,
e Isaac Romero como segunda punta, cuidado.
Cuidado lo de Agumé como nueve, cuidado.
Pero partiendo de esa base, obviamente...
A mí me gusta mucho el fútbol de...
O sea, cómo es capaz Bórdalas de sacarle rédito a plantillas
que son muy flojas.
Y yo creo que ahora mismo lo que necesita Sevilla es precisamente eso.
O sea, primero un futbolista que se identifique...
O un entrenador que se identifique con la afición,
un entrenador que sea capaz de sacarle mucho rédito,
de que además los jugadores sean capaces de rendir a un nivel muy alto.
Yo creo que eso Bórdalas lo puede conseguir.
Y sobre todo también un plan que se adecué más a lo que es el Sevilla históricamente.
Es que, Nahuel,
Mitchell no es García Pimienta
porque Mitchell es muy capaz de conectar con la afición.
Creo que tiene mucho carisma.
Pero al final,
Bórdalas es otra cosa.
Creo que el sevillismo...
El sevillismo se puede identificar mucho con Bórdalas.
Y al mismo tiempo creo que Bórdalas necesita más a Sevilla que Mitchell,
que yo no sé si tomaría la decisión de ir no por grandeza de club,
que sería el mejor club en el castado Mitchell.
Esto es así, pero de largo.
Sino por la situación tan complicada que tienen en Nervión.
A ver, por la parte de Mitchell, yo no sé hasta qué punto Mitchell
puede elegir este tipo de cosas.
Al final, las situaciones en los equipos grandes te llegan cuando te llegan.
Y luego, en cuanto a la elección,
percibo cierta unanimidad en torno a Bórdalas.
Entonces, cuando tienes un entorno tan crispado,
le tienes que dar a la gente lo que pide.
Esto ya pasó en Valencia.
Cuando se abre la ventana de,
a ver, ¿qué hacemos después de la temporada tan horrible previa a Bórdalas?
Dices, oye, Bórdalas de cajón.
Entonces, yo no le daría muchas más vueltas
si las condiciones son parecidas, que parece que sí,
que ambos tienen contrato para la temporada que viene,
que habría que negociar con Género,
que habría que negociar con Getafe y Girona
para pagar una recesión.
Imaginaos a este tipo en un derbi sevillano.
Habías ido a por eso.
Había ido a por esto. A por la estampita, que la llevo en la cartera.
He ido a por la cartera porque llevo la estampita.
Siempre me protege de todo.
A ver, yendo a la…
Igual con más posibilidades económicas
se puede repescar a otro de los apóstoles que ya no está en Getafe.
Matías Olivera.
Por ejemplo.
La segunda avenida de Davidson.
Pero recordemos que…
El personal recuperado la nuestra. La nueve.
Pero recordemos que si algo no tiene el Sevilla
que ofrecerle a Bordalas…
Son quita. Son perras.
Es que claro…
A ver, Davidson quiere decir…
No, Davidson sí.
… que pueden pedir por Davidson.
No, ya, ya. Pero a lo que voy…
Es verdad lo que dices, Nahuel,
de que un club grande tú no eliges el momento, ¿no?
Salvo quizás a un caso muy concreto, no eliges el momento.
Creo…
Chavy creo que lo eligió en cierta medida, ¿no?
Cuando dice no primero, luego va…
Bien, eso puede suceder.
Chavy, no Xavi, por cierto.
Pero…
Xavi también está eligiendo bastante.
Sí, puede ser.
Le dice Karel Weyern, le dice no al Liverpool…
Claro, pero…
Pero claro, son ejemplos muy concretos y sobre todo…
Algo que voy a decir es que no es que el Sevilla esté en una mala temporada.
O sea, no estamos con el Sevilla
después del OPT, ¿vale?
Sino que estamos con un Sevilla en una crisis institucional gigantesca,
con una crisis económica galopante,
donde se le ha pedido a Horta,
porque Horta lo ha explicado,
y del Nido Carrasco,
que no duda en contradecir a Horta
cuando así lo creo oportuno,
se ha callado,
a Horta le han pedido rejuvenecer la plantilla
y recortar el coste de la misma al 50%.
O sea, al director deportivo
no le han pedido configurar una plantilla para pelear por Europa.
No le han pedido reverdecer
viejos, entre comillas, lo de viejos laureles.
No, no. Le han pedido ajustarse económicamente.
Entonces, en ese contexto de economía de guerra,
que es la que tiene el Sevilla y no se puede mentir ni engañar a la gente,
que además creo que lo sabe de sobre allí,
es que Bordalas es oro,
porque recordemos que Bordalas este año comienza
con una plantilla que no se puede presentar a un amistoso.
Entonces, ¿Michel podría hacerlo bien?
Podría hacerlo bien, pero ni tiene una plantilla,
ni el Sevilla tiene musculo económico para adaptarla,
ni veo necesario tomar ese riesgo cuando tienes la opción de Bordalas,
que es lo peor que puede pasar con Bordalas.
Es que Bordalas, en segunda, tiene una barbaridad de éxitos,
aunque tardas en llegar a primera,
y en primera, joder, es que ha hecho un gran papel.
Es que no falla, Bordalas.
Y no sé hasta qué punto...
Y que no hay que pagar por él, eh.
Que no hay que pagar por él.
Y no sé hasta qué punto este Sevilla le va a dar tiempo a Michel
para desarrollar el juego que quiere Michel.
Fijaos lo que ha pasado con García Pimienta,
su mal arranque de temporada,
y llega esa renovación del presidente de la que ya hemos hablado.
Viendo la plantilla del Sevilla, de Mardi Sack, Romero y Agumé,
por ejemplo, Nemanja Gúdel, con su veteranía,
sería capitán general también con Bordalas,
su perfil muy Bordalas.
Y creo que algún otro en la plantilla...
Juanlu. ...el que Bordalas podría sacarle.
Bastante partido.
Porque Bordalas, la historia es que sí que tiene...
O sea, en transformar por el que acaba de contratar en el 25,
pero lo que decía Emilio Contreras es que sí que tiene contrato.
Lo que pasa es que tiene un entendimiento de poder salir.
Claro, lo que nos contaba Emilio, qué buena información tienes.
Claro, no sé si eso es un pacto verbal, escrito o no,
pero que entre Ángel Torres y Bordalas existía esa...
Bueno, que si llegaba a un club más importante,
y desde luego, aunque ahora sea la duda,
pero lo es el Sevilla Fútbol Club, podía salir.
Hablando de entrenadores, Jluis Echado o Lechado,
siempre tengo la duda aquí con nuestro amigo JL,
¿qué entrenador...
Des, des.
Hombre, pero no hay duda, o sea, José Luis Lechado, o sea...
Ya, pero...
Jluis Lechado.
Sí, pero aunque conozca el nickname...
No hay otra combinación posible.
Sí, pero aunque conozca el nickname,
me salta el alerta que yo llamo Larry.
Sí, de que...
Claro, el alerta Larry.
Claro, lo más turbas, ¿no?
Claro, claro, salta esa alerta,
entonces intento coger otra carretera,
aunque al final, pues bueno, todas desembocan donde desembocan.
Estuvo muy bien Nico Rodríguez recogiendo el tema de...
Oye, vamos a hacer como que a mí no ha pasado nada.
Sí, sí, sí.
Demasiado buen compañero, bajo mi punto de vista.
El caso es que JL dice,
¿qué entrenador consideráis más esencial
en el buen hacer de su equipo?
No vale Flick, Ancelotti ni Simeone
por aquello que estábamos preguntando, por nosotros 17.
Como creo que tenemos uno todos en mente.
Claro.
Eh...
Creo que...
Efe, también también.
Eres tú. Sí, sí, sí.
Para mí, para mí.
Hombre, lo digo porque habíamos dicho
que, oye, como se equivoque el Valencia,
que se meta en Europa,
el premio a lo mejor de entrar la temporada
igual se lo puede levantar a Flick.
Yo creo que iba por ahí, pero por supuesto...
Claro que no. Hay dos calvos y uno con pelo para mí.
Yo... A ver, yo es que creo que lo de Giralde...
Bueno, claro, dos calvos, es verdad.
Que, aparte, hace mucha gala el otro calvo de no tener pelo.
¿Cómo? Cuando le plantea algo muy complicado en rueda de prensa
dice sí y a mí me encantaría tener pelo.
Sí, sí, sí.
Es una salida fantástica.
Pero es que yo lo de Giralde le doy un tremendo mérito
porque tenía al Celtismo tremendamente apagado y desconectado
Rafa Benítez, a pesar de estar en año del centenario.
Coge un equipo que no se puede reforzar.
Ojo, también esto es para el Loal Valencia.
Se inventa una barbaridad de futbolistas útiles
para la primera plantilla,
que si en Giralde no estarían en la primera plantilla.
Les está haciendo jugar como los Ángeles.
Están en Europa.
Es que para mí...
Sin Giralde no se puede explicar la historia del Celta.
Sé que se incorporará a la reacción del Valencia tampoco.
Lo comprendo, lo debordarás en el Getafe.
Pero creo que es el entrenador cuyo porcentaje de influencia
es más importante, más decisivo en los otros 17.
Porque quizás con Flick podía haber ese giro de tuerca.
Sí, creo que aquí estamos todos de acuerdo.
Yo sumaría también el nombre de Ernesto Valverde en el Athletic Club.
Creo que... 100%.
El Chingurri está haciendo un trabajazo con ese equipo.
Y más esta temporada combinando tantas competiciones
y haciendo tan buenas rotaciones.
Creo que está funcionando muy bien la plantilla.
Es que hay mucho equipo de autores en la Liga.
Siempre. Tenemos esa suerte, sí.
Está el tema de Íñigo,
que es cierto que recoge una herencia de ir a Ola,
pero que creo que un par de vueltas de rosca más.
Es que yo destacaría fácil ocho o diez entrenadores
que han elevado el techo a sus equipos.
Manolo González, por ejemplo.
La guardarás, claro. Es que...
No, no.
Es que creo que España es país de entrenadores y de centrocampistas.
Eso lleva a que muchas veces es todo muy táctico, muy cerebral,
falta un poquito de locura en el juego.
Bien, de acuerdo.
Pero es que así somos muy competitivos
y así jugamos realmente bien
a fútbol de selecciones y a fútbol de clubes.
Esa es la realidad.
De hecho, el otro día yo reflexionaba mucho
porque veía a los ingleses hacer análisis
del Paris Saint-Germain Arsenal.
Y claro, el Arsenal y el Paris Saint-Germain
son dos equipos que se cimentan bajo dos entrenadores españoles.
Y claro, ellos están centrando mucho el partido,
en los duels, en la velocidad, en tal y no sé qué,
cuando el partido da muy rico en cuanto a táctica y centro de ampismo.
La posición de Vitinha, cómo al Arsenal tiene que ajustar la presión,
etcétera, etcétera.
Y obviamente se veía mucho la mano de nuestro fútbol ahí.
Bueno, no hemos hablado de Marcelino tampoco.
Claro. Mira...
Pero aquí hay un giro...
Yo estoy de acuerdo contigo, Nahuel, pero aquí hay un giro
que nos plantea Inception 1923,
que tiene... Yo le puedo comprar una parte, no el final, ¿vale?
Dice así, ¿qué valoración hacéis de la temporada del Villarreal?
¿Qué nota le ponéis ahora mismo?
Faltan cinco jornadas, el Villarreal está a sexto.
¿Qué nota le ponéis?
Yo un ocho y medio.
Yo un...
No tanto no, pero...
El Villarreal está quinto, si no me equivoco.
Quinto, quinto, claro. No, no, por supuesto, por supuesto.
Perdona, con el lío de la posición de Champions me confundo.
Para mí es un siete.
Es cierto que los partidos de casa ha dejado mucho que desear
y últimamente ha habido partidos donde han podido conseguir más
y no lo ha hecho, pero...
Yo estoy con el siete, Nahuel.
Puedes irte a la cerámica, por cierto.
Me gusta, sí.
Me gusta, sí, el siete.
Esto va relacionado porque parecía el máximo favorito al Top 4,
yo le metía así, en el Top 4,
y va a tener que luchar por la quinta plaza
que da acceso a Champions, pero no por mérito del Villarreal,
sino por mérito del Betis, del Barça, del Athletic Club, etcétera.
Con un Betis que en enero parecía fuera de la pelea.
Si no se clasifica a Champions o lo hace de rebote,
destituiríais a Marcelino.
Yo esto creo que no aplica.
El Villarreal es quinto
porque el Athletic Club está haciendo una puntuación.
Durante varias jornadas hemos dicho,
oye, ¿le metemos en la pelea por el título?
Pero siendo esto cierto, Nahuel,
¿no esperabas algo?
O sea, mi sensación es que el equipo con Marcelino
rápidamente se recupera del trabajo del año pasado, es formidable,
tiene un muy buen arranque esta temporada,
creo que también con un puntito de timing,
muchos goles en el descuento a Yoz y tal,
pero ¿no tienes la sensación de que no ha evolucionado durante el curso?
Que es como un poco el mismo equipo y que no ha logrado ajustar...
Es que yo he hecho en falta control en los partidos al Villarreal.
Es que al final,
la expectativa de que el Villarreal fuera cuarto
tenía mucho que ver con que era el más potente
de los que no tenían competición europea.
Es que el Athletic Club ha manejado muy bien,
sorprendentemente bien la exigencia
de estar competiendo cada tres días toda la temporada.
Yo no lo esperaba y más teniendo el caramelo
de la final de la Europa League en San Mamés.
Puede ser.
Es que...
En Valencia con 60 puntos se metió el Champions.
El Valencia-Granfelino. Pero, Nahuel, aún así le pones un 7.
¿Por qué le pones un 7 entonces?
No, porque creo que ha tenido partidos en casa donde...
El equipo ha tenido un limbo entre diciembre-febrero
de resultados y de falta de consistencia,
que creo que ha sido negativo.
Pero luego, al final, si te vas al verano,
es que el Villarreal ficha jugadores por hacer.
No ficha certezas de, oye, voy a amarrar la cuarta plaza.
Sí o sí.
Tiene un meritazo.
Yo creo que tiene mucho mérito la temporada del Villarreal.
O sea, al final...
Está mejor el Athletic Club, pero bueno, es algo aceptable.
Puede ser.
Al final de este año al Villarreal se le va su portero titular
y su delantero titular.
Y a partir de ahí tiene que rehacer el equipo y ficha.
Sí, de la Liga.
Claro, ficha jugadores que tienen muy buena...
Segundo, sí.
Tienen jugadores que tienen muy buena pinta,
pero que no se sabe cómo van a rendir en ese gran nivel.
Sí que ficha es una certeza en Ayoce,
pero el resto es una apuesta.
No, no, no.
Cuando tienes una apuesta, Tierno Barri es una apuesta.
Yo estoy de acuerdo con eso,
por eso creo que tiene mucho, salvo Ayoce,
el resto es verdad.
Tiene mucho mérito que el Villarreal haya sido tan competitivo
juntando tantas piezas nuevas en el mismo equipo
que lo haya hecho de esta manera.
Siendo tan competitivo al principio,
yo esperaba alguna evolución al respecto.
Bueno, yo creo que ha habido evolución.
Ha pasado a ser un equipo mucho más estable a nivel defensivo.
Sí. Yo creo que es un mérito.
Para mí esa es la evolución del Villarreal,
que ha pasado a ser un equipo que antes era una feria.
O sea, una feria en las dos direcciones podía pasar de todo.
Hay partidos de mucho marcador,
el partido frente al Celta de Vigo,
marcadores muy altos,
y que ahora se están manejando en marcadores un poquito más bajos
o intentando dar un poco más de seguridad a su propia defensa.
Y que ha tenido, Adri, bajas muy duras.
El tema de Ilias, cuando estaba brillante, le hace mucho daño.
Oye, ese ha habido que no ha sacado nunca.
Claro, le ha costado volver.
El tema de Foiz, que por fin ha vuelto esta temporada
después de tantísimo tiempo con idas y venidas.
Juegadores que han consolidado.
El tema de Sergi Cardona que...
Pero, chicos, yo compro el tema de los refuerzos,
el de las lesiones no, porque...
¿Qué decir? Todos los equipos tienen lesiones importantes
y no creo que el Villarreal haya tenido más que el resto.
El tema de Ilias con la primera vuelta...
El Betis, la primera vuelta, estaba lastradísimo por las lesiones.
Lastradísimo.
Acuérdate de Johnny con problemas, problemas en los laterales...
Había muchos problemas.
El Atleti Clubs seguramente que no.
Pero por eso la nota del Betis es más alta que la del Villarreal.
¿No?
Bueno, las pondremos...
La exigencia de Europa...
Para mí, el Villarreal es un 7,
Betis, Atleti y Clubs estarían encima.
Las pondremos a final de temporada.
Decía Adris esta cuestión de Álex Suárez.
¿Qué jugadores de equipos que luchan por la permanencia?
Y yo definiría la lucha por la permanencia ahora mismo.
De Sevilla para abajo.
Sevilla, Girona, la vez Unión Deportiva,
Unión Deportiva Las Palmas y Leganés.
¿Qué jugadores de equipos que luchan por la permanencia
veis capaces de ser importantes en un equipo que pelea?
Entrar a Europa.
Lo que podría ser un Celta, uno Sessuña o un Mallorca.
Insisto, del Sevilla al Leganés,
nombra un par, Adri.
Así vamos un par cada uno.
Sevilla, Leganés...
Pobre, del Sevilla, Luquevacchio.
Sí.
Pero que Dodi Luquevacchio es futbolista para estar ahí.
Y de Las Palmas, Faios Silva.
Yo creo que son los dos más evidentes de esa pelea.
Porque son los dos mejores futbolistas
de esos últimos cinco equipos en la clasificación, los seis.
Alex.
Yo estoy un poco por ahí, la verdad.
Sinceramente...
Pero nombra...
Nombra otros dos, porque en el Girona hay unos cuantos.
Sí, sí.
A mí, si Brian Gino se hubiera lesionado,
me parece que lo podría ser.
Obviamente, Creechi.
Yo estaría muy en el barco de un Carlos Vicente...
Como le vimos en el tramo final
o en la segunda parte de la temporada pasada
en sus primeros minutos en primera.
Y, obviamente, a mí el uno que me encanta, que es Moleiro.
Pues que te sale un once, ¿eh?
Hay mucho jugador muy potente.
Hacemos un once.
Hacemos un once. Míralo, fíjate.
Miguel, juego para cuando amabe la temporada.
Un once.
Con solo jugadores de los tres equipos que han descendido
para ver si podría entrar en competición europea.
Pero vamos a hacer todos más o menos lo mismo.
Tiene poquito de juego el tema, Álex, pero no te preocupes.
Ya haremos...
Ya haremos alguno...
Hacemos...
A mí me gusta, Álex.
Tenemos que encontrar un juego en el que puedas simultanear
a Zaharian con Shingraven.
No sé qué juego va a ser.
Y Owen. Sí, sí, sí.
Hay que encontrar la codatura del circo.
Empezamos en portería.
Marcos Ibera debería ser el portero.
Estoy de acuerdo con Ibera barra Dimitrovic.
Pero... Sí, es que Ibera ha bajado un pelín.
Se nota que de hecho la lesión...
Yo de hecho...
Mi duda con Ibera sería más Cilesen o incluso Nilan
que no tanto Dimitrovic.
En el... En el LdR, eh.
En el LdR, chicos...
A ver, hay de todo.
Rozier, ¿no? Rozier.
Carmona, Rozier, Tenaglia...
Pero vamos a ir rápido.
Hay muchas opciones, pero para hacer un once rápido.
Empezamos con Ibera y Rozier.
Krejci, Bade.
Bade. Bade.
En el lateral izquierdo, Miguel Gutiérrez.
Sí. Miguel, sí.
En el centro del campo, no lo habéis dicho, Antonio Blanco.
Muy bueno. Lo hemos dicho para pedido dos, Miguel.
Ya, bueno, coño, pero por eso no lo habéis dicho.
Joder, Nau.
Tenéis por...
¿Es Hugo? No nos llames...
¿Es Hugo o es tu hijo?
No, pero podría ser, ¿no?
Ese chiste ya lo he hecho. Ese chiste ya lo he hecho antes.
Es Hugo... A ver, ha bajado es Hugo,
pero a mí me ha gustado mucho el principio, sí.
Es Hugo, Antonio Blanco, es buena pareja, sí.
En derecha, Luke Vaccio habéis dicho, evidentemente.
En izquierda, Brian Hill, ¿no?
Sí, si estuviera sano.
En la punta, Moleiro.
En izquierda, Moleiro, yo creo, eh.
No, le damos la media punta.
Le damos la media punta en vez de a Raba,
le damos la media punta a Moleiro,
que creo que es jugador de pelea por Europa y arriba, Fabio Silva.
Ahora, este once te dice mucho del mérito que tiene el Leganés, eh.
Creo que han inundido al cine.
Muy pocas de las mejores piezas de esa pelea.
Hemos metido a Rozier...
A un Renato Tapia, a un Neyú...
Pero... No, no, no.
Podrías que están en esa pelea.
Para mí es criminal lo que ha pasado en el mercado invierno.
Creo que es lo que le ha terminado condenando a...
Pero este equipo, chicos, sí que pelearía por Europa.
O sea, recordamos, Sibera, Rozier,
Vadé,
Miguel... Creichi,
Miguel Gutiérrez, Antonio Blanco,
Esugo, Luque Bakio, Moleiro, Braian Gil,
Fabio Silva... Esto compite por Europa, pero vamos.
Vamos. Antonio...
Es lo que nos hemos dejado fuera, eh.
Sí, sí, sí.
Aunque entrenador.
Michel.
De los de abajo. Michel, ¿no?
Sí, Michel.
Pimienta o Michel, sí.
O Borja, eh.
En el doble pivote... Pimienta cuenta como Owen,
¿no? Ahora mismo.
Bueno, en el doble pivote, Antonio Blanco...
No está. Dijo a Quín Caparrós.
Pero estuvo, pero estuvo.
Ah, bueno, pues está.
Pero, hombre, Braian Gil...
Lleva a tener un jugador... Claro.
Braian Gil está lesionado.
No, pero...
Pero está.
Braian Gil tiene la misma posibilidad de jugar el próximo partido
el Girona que Owen.
No, entrenador Luis García Plaza.
Carrión. Claro.
Entrenador Carrión.
Mira, por suerte...
Yo iba a decir, en el doble pivote, Antonio Blanco, Kirian.
Sí. Kirian...
Sí.
Por eso está jugando.
Claro, sí, sí.
Bueno, bueno, bueno.
Va a jugar, va a jugar.
Va a volver.
¿Se puede poner a Doppik del Girona?
Mira, séptima cuestión, que me representa bastante.
Estoy tan cansado...
Vale.
Ese es el nick.
Ah, vale, yo digo...
Por eso.
No, no, que me representa bastante.
Estoy tan cansado, me gusta.
Os tenéis que quedar con una solución, ¿vale?
Vale.
Si tuvierais que pelear por la permanencia,
¿qué preferís, un 9 de más de 15 goles
o una pareja centrales con nivel confidence Europa League?
Un 9.
Yo no, los centrales.
He visto a equipos bajar con el Zarra.
Pero el tema es...
Claro, ¿cómo meter los 15 goles en 9?
Quiero decir...
No, porque puede ser un 9.
Con la cabeza y las dos piernas.
Con el culo, la buena.
Pero bueno.
Todo es de penalti, todo es de penalti.
No, yo lo digo porque, por ejemplo,
puede ser un 9 tipo Dobik, ¿vale?
Que le tiras una ala de aro y él hace la jugada.
O puede ser un 9 tipo...
Es que Roger Martí tiene una temporada con el Levante
peleando por abajo de 13 goles.
A lo que te refieres es si se fabrica la jugada como Fabio Silva,
por poner un ejemplo,
o si es un rematador como Kike García.
Claro, si es... Exacto.
Si es un Fabio Silva de la vida, vamos, no admite discusión.
Pues me gusta el matiz de la suegra, ¿eh?
Me gusta porque exige menos...
La pregunta es, ¿o Kike García o Willy Kanguala y Logan Costa,
que es una pareja para entrar en Europa?
¿Están entrando en Europa?
Bueno, claro.
¿Están entrando en Europa porque tienen a Jose Pérez?
Claro, están entrando...
Bueno...
De aquella manera, como entró el Vaticano en Europa.
¿Estan ahí, no?
¿Cómo entró el Vaticano en Europa?
¿Cómo fue aquello?
No lo sé, no lo sé.
A lo que me refería era un país pequeñito ahí,
con su propia historia.
¿En San Marino?
¿En San Marino en Europa?
De hecho, es que se me ha ocurrido alguna que otra cosa
y no iba a citar a ningún ejemplo.
Entonces, no, no, no.
No quiero meterme al día.
Malísimas cosas que tienes que callar, Miguel.
Es absolutamente musulmica.
No, no, es verdad.
Tengo un potencial maligno muy importante,
pero de momento la fuerza es superior en mí, ¿vale?
El Vaticano entró en Europa como un estado independiente
a través del tratado de Letrán en 1929.
A ese me refería.
Firmado Santa Sede y el Reino de Italia.
Al tratado de Letrán.
¿Quién se quedaba con los centrales?
Que tiene Letrán pequeña, ¿no?
Sí, sí.
¿Quién se quedaba con los centrales? ¿Eras tú, Álex?
Yo me quedo con los centrales,
porque recientemente he visto caer equipos
que han tenido a jugadores con muchos goles de zanfador.
El caso del español es el más evidente.
José es uno de los máximos goleadores de la Liga,
pero atrás siendo una feria, coincidiendo demasiado
y terminaba perdiendo la categoría.
Aunque yo creo que estaba más vinculado a la portería
que no tanto a los centrales, aunque sí que es verdad
que esos calzaperros no había quien lo arreglaran.
Ni Calero, ni Cabrera, ni César Montes, ni nadie.
Pero, Álex, que...
Pero, mire, goles son muchos, ¿eh?
Que Budimir lleva 18.
Sí, pero, pero, pero, Adri...
Y José Lu...
Pero tiene una cosa... Creo que tiene parte de razón, Álex.
Tú ves, estoy viendo los equipos que han descendido
en los últimos años.
Y, salvo alguno muy concreto... José Lu marca 16 en la 22-23.
Hay un... Salvo alguno muy concreto, por ejemplo, al Cádiz,
que le pones un delante de 15 goles y el Cádiz seguiría con nosotros,
la mayoría son auténticos dramas en defensa.
O sea, el Puzela, ¿qué prefieres, un delantero de 15 goles
o dos centrales? Yo digo dos centrales.
Es verdad que luego hay casos y casos,
pero creo que puede tener cierto sentido lo que dice...
Un delantero de más de 15 goles.
Ante Budimir, ¿vale?
Ante Budimir por un lado.
O Cara Starfeld, Javi Rodríguez y Marcos Alonso.
Pero es que, Adri...
Defensa de Conferencia. Pero no seas perro.
Pero no seas perro. Oye, oye, oye.
Con... Con... Ahí ya son tres.
Defensa de Conferencia.
Tres en vez de uno, claro.
Estoy viendo la defensa de Sevilla. Adri...
Conferencia, es una explicación. Adri...
Con tres centrales, buenos apañas, apañas medio once, Adri.
Adri, han encajado los mismos goles.
Han encajado más goles el Zeta que la Alaves.
Entonces, a mí ese ejemplo no me vale.
Pero es una defensa de Conferencia.
Hay un caso muy mítico.
No vale la de Millar, es de Europa League.
Claro, claro.
Es de Europa League.
Porque han marcado 50 goles.
Claro, claro.
Entra Ante Budimir, hoy, Nigo Martínez y Cuba Símica
con los del Barça, claro.
Es que... Claro.
No, pero...
No, pero, por ejemplo... Mira, mira, mira.
Permíteme ser un poquito menos cazallero
de lo que está siendo Adri.
O Sasuna.
O Sasuna, o Sasuna, ¿vale?
Para el Bajaolid, ¿vale?
Bueno, para el Bajaolid.
Para el Leganés, para el Leganés, ¿vale?
Sí. Bueno, igual te voy a dar la razón.
Budimir... Claro, es que el Leganés...
Budimir, Oenzo Boyomo y Catena Maserrando.
Para el Leganés.
Son tres de nuevo, Miguel.
Bueno, coño, juegan con tres, tío.
¿Qué quieres que hagas? Bueno, han jugado dos.
Juegan tres ahora hace dos ratos.
Para el Leganés solamente Budimir.
Pero si el Leganés tiene a Diego García y Miguel de la Fuente.
Ya, por eso.
He cogido un ejemplo muy pertinente para ti.
A las Palmas. A las Palmas.
A las Palmas.
A las Palmas no le ponía...
Porque tiene a Fabio Silva.
Es que ese ejemplo... A ver, aquí siempre depende.
Yo creo que... A ver, es un debate bonito.
Creo que todas las opciones son buenas y malas.
Pero creo que el apunte que ha dicho Nahuel...
Es un tío...
Coño, que no hay opción buena ni mala.
Sí, pues Nahuel, Nahuel.
Como tú por las noches.
Tú por las noches, si tú atés dos de la mañana,
todas las opciones son buenas...
No me ha visto nunca.
Pero conozco tus andanzas.
Tampoco he visto a Jesucristo y conozco sus milagros.
Hay un caso...
Hay un caso muy mítico de este extremo, que es...
Temporada 2007-2008,
Don Real Zaragoza,
Diego Milito 15 goles, Ricardo Oliveira 18,
y se va a segunda división.
Bueno, el once es una locura.
Los centrarios que eran Gaby, Milito y Sergio Fernández.
No...
Sergio Fernández y Ayala.
Ah, claro, Ayala.
Con Diogo y Juanfran en los laterales,
Zapater, Luchín, Gaby,
Diego Milito, Oliveira, Sergio García.
Esos son los once con César en portería.
Sergio García, que ese año...
No, es el siguiente, el que va a la Eurocopa.
Ese año va a la Eurocopa.
Ese año va a la Eurocopa, sí, 2007-2008.
Pues férjate.
Casi nada.
Hay ejemplos de todo tipo.
Cabeces, penúltima pregunta,
precisamente sobre el Pucela,
pero también sirve para lo que habéis dicho del Leganés.
¿Hay tanta diferencia entre la primera y la segunda
que a equipos como Valle a Olid,
un clásico no le ha dado ni para competir?
No es el caso de la Premier League.
Lo de la Premier League...
Es ahí por donde iba.
No es lo de la Premier League, es una cosa exageradísima.
Exagerada.
Pero tú ves con las plantillas con las que han subido,
Español, Leganés y Valle a Olid,
y, joder, hay diferencia.
A mí me parece que en la segunda división hay mucho talento,
hay muchos jugadores muy buenos.
Por ejemplo, Iker Kortaharena del Huesca,
que se está saliendo en este tramo final.
Hay jugadores que destacan mucho,
y por eso me parece muy interesante
que los equipos de primera se fija tanto en el mercado de segunda.
Así que es verdad que ha habido clubes
que han fichado a disto y sinestro de segunda,
un nombre que destacaba en segunda lo ficho.
Las Palmas.
Las Palmas, claramente.
Y que luego te encuentras una plantilla que tiene Iván Gil,
Amano Fuster, jugadores que podrían rendir
en contextos de otros equipos de primera división,
pero que en la Unión Deportiva de Las Palmas
se encuentran sin posibilidades.
Yo, sinceramente, creo que la plantilla que tiene el Valle a Olid
o que ha tenido el Valle a Olid este año en primera
era peor que la del año pasado.
Lo de Boyomo, por ejemplo, está Regazón Temporadón...
Me parece que el equipo es mucho peor.
El propio Moncho, eso es.
A ver, es que el Valle a Olid es un ejemplo malo por eso,
porque la plantilla es claramente peor,
pero sí que es verdad que, por ejemplo,
tenemos el caso del Granada, que nos refuerza la defensa,
y parece una feria a mí,
me da la sensación de que en segunda cada vez hay peor nivel,
pero es normal, porque al final las direcciones deportivas
cada vez tienen más herramientas.
Cualquier club de la zona baja de Polonia,
solo con tema de estadística avanzada,
puede detectar talento en segunda división
sin tener una secretaria técnica muy grande
y creo que cada vez hay más mercados
que acuden a segunda división a acudir.
Y no solo eso, es también lo que ha dicho Álex,
si hay menos poderío económico en la liga
y la liga no puede acudir a según qué mercados,
acude a su mercado de proximidad, que es la segunda división.
Entonces... La veo muy vacía de talento en la segunda división,
hay jugadores que destacan mucho que luego les cuesta transformar
todo eso... No, y hay ejemplos,
hay ejemplos, joder, tú ves la plantilla de Almería,
que fíjate, que tampoco está en puesto de ascenso directo,
la plantilla de Almería tiene mucha calidad,
tiene mucho talento, pero sí que es verdad
que hay muchos equipos que vienen subiendo
que van con lo justo, van con lo justo y menos.
Luego te encuentras casos como el del Girona,
que evidentemente, claro, también hay que meter el tema
de la multipropiedad, el City Group y demás, pero...
Sí, Gankov fue el factor de diferencia,
yo creo, en esa temporada. Es que yo, por ejemplo,
a mí lo que me da miedo es el tema de la...
La primera tienen a Riquelme, por ejemplo, cedido.
Claro, sí. A mí lo que me da miedo...
Y llega a ese Gankov el tramo final.
A mí lo que me da miedo es la poca capacidad de progresión
que a veces tienen algunos equipos, por ejemplo, el Kadiz.
El Kadiz sube, se queda y la plantilla sigue siendo justísima
y después de varios milagros no puede progresar.
Miguel, esto para mí es clave de un equipo
que baja de primera a segunda y quiere ascender.
Creo que hay mucha tentación
a los contratos de, mira, te firmo en segunda división
un año más, dos más si subimos a primera, por ejemplo, ¿no?
O dos más uno si subimos a primera, renovación automática
si subimos a primera división. Y eso, yo creo, es un error de manual.
Don Real Vagadolid. Claro, Real Vagadolid.
Al Kadiz le pasó también que tenía muchas erecciones de contratos,
pombo, o sea, futbolistas que van a primera, pues, sinceramente,
nunca han terminado de ser ese valor atractivo,
todo ese futbolista que pueda determinar muchas veces una permanencia.
Por lo tanto, también parece un error de manual,
que creo que aumenten muchos equipos de endeudarse en segunda división
para luego llegar a primera y tener muchísimos jugadores
que no le puedes dar salida.
Es que el levante está con recortes en cuanto a personal del club,
a lo bestia, por no poder subir la temporada pasada.
Y se va a plantar en primera división,
a volver a estar en negro en cuanto a
eliminar los números rojos.
Es que es un desastre a nivel competitivo.
Yo diría que tan solo Almería y Oviedo
parecen equipos que tengan potencial económico
como para poder decir, oye, estoy en primera división y voy a invertir.
Y ya estamos hablando de una multipropiedad y un jeque.
Y yo te diría que para mí la mejor dirección deportiva de segunda
es la del racín.
O sea, creo que para un salto a primera me refiero a él.
Me parece que Martí Jadid podría hacer un buen curro.
Seguramente esto que estamos hablando está igualando mucho
la segunda división, que está cada vez más igualada.
Pero seguramente por lo bajo.
Última cuestión, me parece muy interesante.
Siempre la vamos tratando a lo largo de la temporada,
pero ya llegamos a un momento donde ya podemos
hablar ya de forma definitiva,
porque las últimas cinco jornadas no se juegan, se compiten
y no se pregunta cómo se gana, se gana y fuera.
Pero nos pregunta Frasen Rack por aquellos equipos
que han sobrepuntuado e infrapuntuado más.
Él nos da una respuesta.
A ver si estáis de acuerdo.
Sobrepuntuado, dice Betis y Español.
Yo con el español puedo estar de acuerdo por el tema Joan García,
que al final es un crack, es un crack, es un jugador que te marca
las diferencias, con el Betis no tanto.
Y dice el álaves infrapuntuando,
lo cual estoy muy de acuerdo.
Estoy en la clasificación.
Esto si fuera una rueda de prensa, Luis Enrique,
tú no te dirías, bueno, te has contestado tú solo.
Bueno, pero podéis dar vuestra opinión.
Sí, a...
El bueno, casi me llevas a tu territorio.
¿Quién os parece que es sobrepuntuado o infrapuntuado
más allá de las respuestas que da él, si estáis de acuerdo o no?
¿Cuáles serían vuestros nombres?
Yo creo que el Rayo ha sobrepuntuado también.
El Rayo ha sobrepuntuado, sí.
Creo que el Rayo es de los que ha sobrepuntuado.
El... El Valencia...
El Valencia en la segunda parte de la temporada ha sobrepuntuado.
Muchos partidos que van al límite han caído a favor.
Oye, perfecto.
La primera fue lo contrario.
Sí, sí, sí. O sea, ¿suna ha sobrepuntuado?
Al principio. Sí.
Por eso. Al principio me suena...
Al principio me suena que dijimos que los que sobrepuntuaban
eran Sevilla, que se cayó,
y Osasuna, que se cayó. Mallorca.
¿Con Mallorca os decimos? Yo creo que también, ¿no?
Ha estado mucho tiempo... El Mallorca ha tenido muchos partidos
de empate en encuentros fuera de casa que lo ha terminado ganando.
Puede ser. En la primera vuelta.
Vale. ¿E infrapuntuado?
¿E infrapuntuado? Para mí el Celta puede estar ahí, ¿no?
El Valladolid.
Se me ha olvidado del Pucela.
Seguro que ha infrapuntuado, porque los puntos que lleva ahora mismo...
Bueno, ¿ves algunas cosas?
Está ahora mismo el Valladolid en el infrapunto, ¿no?
Ahora mismo hay mucha gente pensando que en realidad
ha sobrepuntuado, más que infrapuntuado.
Sobre todo en Valladolid.
¿Habéis dicho alabés, no?
Sí, alabés me parece claro.
Alabés es claro, sí.
Girona tiene... Las palmas...
Girona tiene un punto de eso.
Al final vas a ir todos los 20, ¿eh?
No, yo creo que...
¿No?
Yo diría que no.
Según la estadística avanzada, el que más ha infrapuntuado es el alabés,
que está 17º y según la estadística avanzada debería ir 17º.
Y el que más ha sobrepuntuado es el español,
que debería ir 17º y está 13º.
Más allá de que los X-Point son lo que son
y de que lo del español se explica con Joan García
y lo del alabés con los goles en contra en el tramo final
y la falta de contundencia más allá de Kike García,
yo creo que van un poquito por ahí los tiros,
son los nombres que nos daba él, se puede sumar alguno,
estoy de acuerdo con lo del Rayo,
pero creo que se ha corregido un poquito lo del Valencia,
que decía Nahuel, mal al principio, luego bien.
Al final estas cosas también, te digo,
en general se terminan compensando en una liga de 38 partidos
y luego que hay cosas que podemos decir...
Oye, el español ha sobrepuntuado, ya ves que tiene Joan García.
Claro, eso...
Es que es lo que hay.
Claro, si tuviese, yo qué sé, el Girona, Andrea Pirlo,
el Girona estaría peleando por Europa y no diríamos nada raro,
sino que tiene Andrea Pirlo en el centro del campo, sabes.
O Ante Budimir, si sabes a Budimir, pírate.
Pero el Girona con Pirlo no se metería a su lado en Europa,
se metería a Pirlo los pelos.
Otro sobrepuntuado es el Getafe.
Sí.
El Getafe tuvo un tramo de partidos donde sobrepuntuó claramente
y por eso escapa y quiso soñar con Europa.
Puede ser.
A ver qué ejemplos, pizarritas, se os ocurren a vosotros,
porque esta me parece una cuestión interesante,
también la del delantero y los centrales.
Es un poquito pao-pau-mamá en ese sentido.
Pronto, se viene un suegra o cuñado.
Así que, pizarritas, no os desenganchéis,
que queda poca liga, pero queda mucho contenido en Pizarritas.
Gracias, Adri, Álex, Nahuel.
Gracias, chicos.
Gracias.
Y mañana ya lo sabéis, a partir de las 10 de la mañana,
más pizarrismo.